What is diabetes? Diabetes is a serious condition where your blood sugar levels,
also known as blood glucose levels, are too high. It's diagnosed from a blood test.
There are two main types, type 1 and type 2, which is the most common.
And lots of other types, like gestational diabetes, type 3c and modi.
The causes and symptoms depend on the type of diabetes you have. Diabetes happens
because of a problem with a hormone called insulin. When you eat or drink, any carbohydrates
you've had are turned into glucose, a type of sugar. Insulin acts like a key to unlock
the cells to let the sugar in, to give you energy. If you have diabetes, this can't happen,
so sugar builds up in the blood. High blood sugars over time can cause problems in almost
every part of your body, from your brain to your feet. So treatment is about trying to keep
blood sugars within a target range. Being as active as possible, eating healthy and going
for regular health checks will help you do this. Some people will also need to take insulin or
other medication and check their blood sugars regularly. Lots of things can affect blood sugars,
so it can be tricky to balance. But it's possible to lead a full life. It's about being in
tune with your body and learning what works for you. You can get more support from your medical
team and as here at Diabetes UK.